what are you thoughts on students taking
adderall are there any long-term effects
there are long-term studies of the
utility of adderall for attention
deficit disorder hyperactivity and the
results are basically negative there is
no evidence that the medications help
with academic performance over the long
run I think that adderall is an
amphetamine it is addictive it can
sensitize you to other dopamine agonists
so I would generally say it's something
to be avoided you also want to really
watch it in combination with marijuana
for example or psychedelics because you
can get unlucky and trigger a psychotic
episode and that is not a good thing
because once you have one psychotic
episode you're a bit on the broken side
and it's hard to put yourself back
together so I would say use it sparingly
if at all it's not it's not a good plan
and especially not something good to be
doing eventually